TIMES SINCE 2,013.
BACK HERE IN THE U.S., AT
AMERICAN ELECTION HEADQUARTERS,
REPUBLICANS BREATHE A SIGH OF
RELIEF IN WEST VIRGINIA.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO
BLOCK A REPUBLICAN SENATE
CANDIDATE IN THAT STATE
SUCCEEDED LAST NIGHT.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY HAS
THAT STORY AND A ROUND UP OF THE
EVENING'S OTHER ELECTIONS FROM
WEST VIRGINIA.
>> Reporter: THE SO-CALLED
SWAMP WAS NEARLY SWEPT LAST
NIGHT.
>> I WAS TAUGHT MY WHOLE LIFE,
NO EXCUSES.
>> ELECTORATES DENIED THREE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THEIR BIDS
FOR OFFICE AND ONE REPUBLICAN
NUMBER THAT CHAMP TO RUN FOR
REELECTION.
BUT MITCH McCONNELL IS HAPPY
BECAUSE WEST VIRGINIA DON
BLANKENSHIP, THE CANDIDATE IS
ALICE SURE COULDN'T WIN IN
NOVEMBER WHO COINED THE NAME IT,
COCAINE MITCH, CAME IN THIRD.
THE MAJORITY WINNER LOADED WITH
A PARODY OF THE SHOW NARCO'S.
>> I'M GLAD THE PEOPLE OF
WEST VIRGINIA DECIDED THAT
TICKLER APPROACH OF ATTACKING ME
AND MY FAMILY WAS GOOD FOR A
DISTANT THIRD PLACE.
>> BUT McCONNELL ISN'T THE ONE
WEST VIRGINIA'S WINNER IS
THINKING.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, IF YOU ARE
WATCHING RIGHT NOW, LET ME TELL
YOU, YOUR TWEET WAS HUGE.
>> IT WASN'T HUGE FOR HOUSE
MEMBERS.
CONGRESSMAN EVAN JENKINS WAS A
RUNNER-UP FOR WEST VIRGINIA, AND
CONGRESSMAN LUCA METZLER AND
TODD WERE KILLED WERE CASUALTIES
IN INDIANA WHERE A LESSER-KNOWN
BUSINESSMAN, MICRON, WILL
CHALLENGE INCUMBENT SENATOR JOE
CONNELLY WITH A CAMPAIGN MODELED
ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S.
>> WHEN I SIGN.
I FEEL BACK IN 16, I THOUGHT,
MAYBE WE CAN GET MORE OF US IN
THE SENATE.
>> A TRUMP LIKE CONGRESS WAS
HELPING THE ONLY G.O.P. HOUSE
MEMBER TO ADVANCE AND HE NOW
FACES DEMOCRATIC SENATOR SHERROD
BROWN.
>> MAKE OHIO FIRST AGAIN AND
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AHEAD.
>> RICHARD CORDRAY, AND A
FAVORITE OF SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN EASILY BEAT
DENNIS KUCINICH FOR A CHANCE TO
SUCCEED JOHN KASICH.
>> YOU DEMANDED A CHANGE AND WE
HEARD YOU, WE WANT THE SAME.
SPEAK OUT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S UPCOMING PRIMARY
WHERE DIANNE FEINSTEIN FAILED TO
SECURE HER PARTY'S ENDORSEMENT
IN AN AGGRESSIVE CHALLENGE FROM
STATE SENATOR KEVIN DE LEON, THE
FIELD IS MOSTLY SET, SO THEY ARE
PRESERVING RESOURCES TO BASE A
ROSTER OF REPUBLICANS STILL
BEING FILLED IN.
>> EVERY CANDIDATE THAT WE
WANTED, ONE.
>> REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES HAD
BEEN COMPETING TO BE MOST LIKE
TRUMP.
NOW THEY ARE COMPETING FOR SPOTS
ON HIS CALENDAR AND THEY ALL
THINK A TRUMP RALLY IN A STATE